stellt euch vor wir müssen unsere
gedanken nicht mehr in worte fassen
oder wir könnten direkt von gehirn zu
gehirn miteinander kommunizieren oder
stellt euch vor wir könnten sie in
matrix einfach wissen in unser gehirn
herunterladen
ob karate anatomie oder ein paar
wikipedia-artikel alle fälle innerhalb
von sekunden gespeichert und zugreifbar
hätten wir schon alleine diese zwei
möglichkeiten würde sich unser alltag
grundlegend verändern
bildung wäre kein großartiges problem
mehr und diese neue form der
kommunikation würde jedweder art von
kommunikationstechnologie überflüssig
machen
all das klingt wieder stoff von science
fiction film und genau da kommen die
meisten ideen auch her aber schon heute
forschen experten und wissenschaftler
genau an dieser zukunft an der
schnittstelle zwischen gehirn und
computer
[Musik]
brain computer interfaces kennen wir
alle unsere smartphones haben
touchscreens unsere computer haben maus
und tastatur diese eingabegeräte helfen
uns dabei unsere gedanken unsere befehle
an die maschine in eine sprache zu
übersetzen die ein computer verstehen
kann
und obwohl wir uns nur gegeben haben den
digitalen arbeitsplatz mit einem
schreibtisch einen papierkorb und
ordnern so naturgetreu wie möglich zu
gestalten ist das arbeiten am computer
alles andere als intuitiv ein video zu
öffnen dauert länger als sich eine
situation zu erinnern
eine nachricht getippten dauert länger
als sie zu denken aber es ist nicht nur
die art und weise wie wir mit computern
sprechen die langsam und umständlich ist
wie wir menschen untereinander
kommunizieren mit worten ist ineffektiv
wir alle müssen jeden tag unsere
komplexen vielschichtigen gedanken in
wien jahre worte fassen und hoffen dass
unser gegenüber diese worte wieder
auseinander nimmt die bedeutung
entschlüsselt und diese sich zu mehr
oder weniger gleichen gedanken in seinem
gehirn ergeben
brain computer oder brain machine
interfaces sollen genau diesen schritt
ersetzen
mit ihnen sollen gedanken direkt von
mensch zu mensch kopiert werden können
und wie wird auch der wichtigste schritt
um mit künstlicher intelligenz gleichauf
zu bleiben
aber fangen wir erst mal von vorne an
schon vor 5000 jahren in ägypten
forschten die ersten menschen am gehirn
und versuchten zu verstehen wie er
funktioniert im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts müssen wir zugeben dass wir
damit nicht wirklich weitergekommen sind
nicht umsonst sind sich viele experten
einig dass das menschliche gehirn das
komplexeste objekte im universum mit
na gut wir haben schon eine recht gute
vorstellung welcher teil des gehirns
welche aufgaben übernimmt und wie
unternehmen im moment die ersten
schritte mit wichtigen rain machine
interface
so können zum beispiel menschen mit
prothesen nur mit der kraft ihrer
gedanken diese prozesse steuern wir
können blinde menschen mit hilfe einer
kamera wieder zum sehen verhelfen und im
jahr 2015 fand das erste gehirn zu
gehirn gespräch statt zwei teilnehmer
eines versuchs der universität von
washington wurden mit eeg geräten
ausgestattet und über einen computer
miteinander verbunden
mithilfe sind klein ja nein fragen
konnte ein teilnehmer das objekt erraten
welche sich der andere teilnehmer
ausgedacht hatte von der sciencefiction
vorstellung mit seiner gedankenkraft
sprechen zu können sind wir also noch
weit entfernt und trotzdem dringend
einige große investoren gerade in den
markt ein und wollen an dieser
potenziellen zukunft vorstelle macht der
gründer von spacex und ceo von tesla hat
2016 die firma new orleans gegründet die
sich auf die erforschung eines brain
computer interfaces und in regierung mit
künstlicher intelligenz fokussiert mit
kölner setzten sich ein weiteres start
up aus dem silicon valley bereits vorher
ein ähnliches 4
hier spielt auch die verbesserung der
kognitiven fähigkeiten eine rolle
schneller denken sich besser sachen
merken können um noch irgendwas dritter
es ist auch klar warum diese investoren
interesse an dem projekt haben sollte
die kommunikation mit hilfe von gehirnen
funktionieren dann wären sämtliche
geräte die uns helfen mit computerchips
zu sprechen mit einem schlag überflüssig
smartphones computer fernseher sämtliche
medien sogar das lenkrad im auto wenn
autos bis dahin nicht umhin schon selber
fahren können
okay wie würde so ein interface aussehen
oder funktionieren
um das zu verstehen müssen wir erst
einmal verstehen wie unser gehirn
funktioniert das ist nämlich ein
riesiges netzwerk aus neuronen und
verbindungen zwischen neuronen den
sogenannten sie nachts zurück
jedes neuron hat ein aktionspotenzial
dass wenn es überschritten wird dafür
sorgt dass das neuron einen stromimpuls
auskennt wird
dieser wird abhängig von den
aktionspotenziale der umliegenden
neuronen weitergegeben oder eben nicht
weitergegeben
soweit funktioniert unser gehirn ähnlich
wie ein computer mit zu neuronen
anstelle von transistoren nur dass in
unserem gehirn jeder stromimpuls die
aktionspotentiale verschiedener neuronen
verändert und sich somit das netzwerk
als ganze verändert und weiterentwickelt
durch wiederholungen kann man diese
veränderungen festigen
deswegen müssen wir beim lernen vieles
wiederholen und regelmäßig trainieren um
in einem sport zu werden
wir verändern mit jedem gedanken jeder
bewegung unser gehirn um es auf die
speziellen anforderungen anzupassen
das was und wer wir sind ist also
eigentlich nur die zusammensetzung der
neuronen
hören wenn man also genau wüsste wie
alle neuronen in meinem kopf miteinander
verbunden sind und welche
aktionspotenziale wir haben dann könnte
man rein theoretisch mein gehirn in
einem computer simulieren und für unsere
zwecke
wenn wir genau wissen würden wann welche
neuronen stromimpuls abgeben dann
müssten wir was dieser mensch gerade
denkt und genau da setzt ein brain
computer interfaces an functional
magnetic resonance imaging cgi kennt
eigentlich jeder aus dem krankenhaus
grundsätzlich werden beim fmo ein
magnetischer felder in kombination mit
radio und anderen quellen genutzt
hiermit können wir sehen wo das gehirn
gerade aktiv ist also wie viele neuronen
gerade aktiviert werden
für einen brain computer interface wäre
diese technologie allein wegen der größe
wohl kaum geeignet
ein weiterer nachteil ist die geringe
räumliche und zeitliche auflösung das
heißt dass nur gehirnbereiche als ganzes
beobachtet werden können und nicht
einzelne neuronen und das der
reaktionszeit punkt nicht genau bestimmt
werden kann
beim eeg verfahren werden einem
elektroden an verschiedenen stellen am
kopf angebracht erzählt für einen hohen
umfang und relativ gute zeitliche
genauigkeit dafür aber extrem schlechte
räumliche auflösung
auch hier können nur grobe bereiche des
gehirns beobachtet werden
eine weitere methode namens ag nutzt
eine ähnliche vorgehensweise wie das eeg
verfahren mit dem einzigen unterschied
dass die elektroden im kopf direkt auf
dem gehirn angebracht werden mit ece
erreicht man immerhin einen hohen umfang
und auch eine bessere zeitliche
präzision im vergleich zum eeg die
räumliche auflösung bleibt aber sehr
schlecht
die locals viel potenzial methode ist
eine der wenigen technologien bei denen
keine großflächigen elektroden genutzt
werden sondern nadeln diese nadel
elektroden werden direkt auf dem gehirn
angebracht was das ganze natürlich
extrem innovativ macht leider erreicht
man damit zurzeit neben hoher zeitlicher
präzision nur einen geringen umfang und
eher weniger räumliche auflösung als
letztes gibt es noch das single you and
recording welches ähnliche nadel
elektronen benutzt hierbei werden aber
einzelne neuronen angepeilt und je nach
elektroden art entweder nur berührt oder
teilweise in eine kleine öffnung
eingesaugt um eine noch höhere präzision
zu erzielen
hierdurch wird zwar eine extrem hohe
auflösung sowohl räumlich als auch
zeitlich empfiehlt jedoch ist die
methode die innovativste von allen
erreicht zurzeit nur einen extrem
kleinen umfang man kann also nur sehr
wenige von unseren 100 milliarden
neuronen gleichzeitig beobachten
generell hoffen wissenschaftler dass
sich diese methoden ähnlich entwickeln
wie die transistoren in computerchips
exponentiell wollen immer mehr neuronen
auf engstem raum beobachtet werden
können und das in zukunft möglichst auch
ohne dafür den schädel öffnen zu müssen
aber selbst wenn wir die neuronen eines
menschen mithilfe dieser technologien
aus werden könnten müssten wir noch
lange nicht was sie damit anstellen
sollten die daten einfach in ein anderes
gehirns übertragen setzt voraus dass wir
wüssten wo dieser mensch seine gedanken
abspeichert da wir unsere gehirne aber
ständig verändern und unterschiedliche
menschen auch automatisch
unterschiedliche strukturen im gehirn
haben kann man nicht einfach eins zu
eins stromimpulse übertragen und hoffen
dass der empfänger das als gedanken
interpretiert unsere größte hürde stellt
also ein simpler fakt da wir wissen von
unserem gehirn quasi nicht es gibt ein
sprichwort in der neurowissenschaft wenn
das menschliche gehirn so einfach wäre
dafür verstehen könnten dann wären wir
menschen so einfach dass wir es nicht
können kann ein objekt sich überhaupt
zur gänze selber verstehen oder spricht
das gegen die naturgesetze unseres
universums
es gibt allerdings einen
hoffnungsschimmer die meisten
wissenschaftler auf dem gebiet sind sich
einig dass wir das gehirn nicht zu 100
prozent verstehen müssen um einen brain
computer interface zu implementieren
[Musik]
neuronale netze ein teilgebiet der
künstlichen intelligenz basieren selber
auf dem prinzip des menschlichen gehört
ein computerprogramm das sich selber
ständig verändert und dadurch lernt die
angst vieler ist dass diese künstliche
intelligenz irgendwann intelligenter
wird als jeder mensch und kurz darauf
auch intelligenter als alle menschen
zusammen
auto und fotoagentur 22 diesen punkt als
die technologische singularität brain
computer interfaces sollen und helfen
mit dieser künstlichen intelligenz zu
interagieren und wie auf dauer in uns zu
integrieren
mit ihr könnten wir unsere eigene
intelligenz steigern erinnerungen
verbessern und unser gehirn bewusst
umstrukturieren und wird zum beispiel
glücklicher machen
die welt ist nur so wie wir sie
wahrnehmen ob das alles wirklich so
funktioniert bleibt abzuwarten
die ganze wissenschaft steckt noch in
den kinderschuhen aber es lohnt sich die
frage zu stellen wollen wir das
überhaupt
ob matrix new romantic oder black mirror
es gibt hunderte fiktionen die sich
schon überlegt haben wie so ein schiff
im kopf oder ein betriebssystem im
gehirn aussehen könnte und ich denke die
überwältigende mehrheit davon sind dies
trug ihm ist man mit einer künstlichen
intelligenz im kopf überhaupt noch
menschlich ist eine simulierte realität
so schön sie auch sein mag lebenswert
und ob es nun der staat oder eine große
firma ist irgendjemand könnte in dieser
zukunft jeden meiner gedanken lesen
nichts wäre mehr privat ist könnte nicht
einmal mehr hügel flügen ist ein
interessantes thema denn eigentlich
können wir schon heute nicht in der
übung unser gehirn sendet unterbewusst
signale auf mimik gestik körper schweiz
die darauf hindeuten dass jemand nicht
die wahrheit sagt begleitet mich mit auf
den kanal von fünf witzig wo wir
zusammen einen lügendetektor gebaut
haben und ich daran angeschlossen werde
dazu einfach hier klicken und ansonsten
geht ein riesiges dankeschön an meine
patrick petri ohne die dieses video hier
nicht möglich gewesen wäre
dankeschön für eure unterstützung
telepathische gehören zu den höhen grüße
gehen raus und ich werde eure namen
jetzt vorlesen weil hier das park auf
die weltcup vor wenn ich das falsch
aussprechen
die man raum kleinen studio verriet
halle in halle jon alexander sebastian
peter andré alt pirat tobias lui piano
jorge posada kuhn enrico kaye applaus
und jens und niklas glaube hinter niklas
beim letzten mal schon dabei egal
vielen dank dass nämlich auf pagewizz
unterstützt oder den vielen zuschauern
bis zum nächsten mal
patrick